if there's one Bitcoin chart that you
need right now in this cycle it's
probably going to be this one and here's
why we've seen a break of the macro
downtrend and we're now seeing a macro
uptrend a new one going into the Haring
and we've seen this so many times before
so we're going to be talking about this
chart in a lot more detail into these
videos so subscribe to the channel for
more videos like this in the future like
this video if you enjoy content like
this going forward and let's dive right
into it macro downtrend that always
signifies at least a yearlong market
downtrend then we break Beyond this
macro downtrend into a new macro uptrend
and you can see here 2016 reaccumulation
period does it look a bit similar to the
reaccumulation period we saw in 2023
really interesting to see those
similarities around a harving pre
harving retrace tends to occur could we
see that occur closer to April as well
but in 2019 we saw a break and then a
pull back for multiple months and then
that March 2020 crash before reversing
into that uptrend so if we look at
history 2016 the Haring year because of
course 2015 is when we broke out here
but then we transitioned into the Haring
year reaccumulation going into the
harving year and then breakout preh
harving retrace and then rallying to new
all-time highs for multiple months
multiple months so you can see that
going into harving we see a lot of
upside volatility downside volatility
pre harving retraces but it's after the
harving where things are very simple we
see parabolic price action to new
all-time highs and that's going to be
the case going forward so we know that
the macro downtrend is over the macro
uptrend the new one is in progress we
could see some sort of pulling back
could we see some sort of pulling back
on the way to the harving could we see
another reaccumulation period occur
could we see another preh Haring retrace
occur like we've seen in the past these
are all possibilities going into the
Haring but after the Haring it's very
simple pre posing parabolic rallying to
new all time highs which is what we are
going to be now transitioning into this
chart we're going to be transitioning
into this chart because after the har we
tend to see a bull market of around 518
days that's the case after the 2016
Haring after the 2020 Haring we saw 546
days
so it comes down to a period of just
over 500 days after the Haring where we
see a new alltime high for Bitcoin and a
bull market Peak for Bitcoin so if this
were to be the case once again mid
September 2025 or mid October 2025 is
where we'd see that bull market Peak
occur and we need to understand also
that it's not just about a new alltime
high forming because we saw a new
alltime high develop many times in this
cycle we're talking about a bull market
Peak taking place and it could occur in
late
2025 which is as you'll note the
beginning of a new 4year cycle and a new
fouryear cycle tends to begin in 2021 or
at least this is 2021 right in also
2017 and 2025 so that's every four years
where we see a bull market Peak and
going in into that PO Haring period we
need to try and position ourselves
appropriately and to position ourselves
appropriately is to focus on this preh
Haring period and during this preh
harving period of around still over 100
days well over a 100 days going into the
Haring we tend to see still either
reaccumulation and the preh Haring rally
we can also see relief rallying pulling
back of course blacks on event so we
might not see that again but a preh
Haring rally nonetheless so we'll
probably see a pre harving rally closer
to the harving two months before the
Haring event could we see some sort of
pulling back even in 2016 we saw some
pulling back which was 25% to the
downside within this reaccumulation
range before we broke out preh harving
retrace preh harving retrace here as
well and preing retrace could take place
going forward but this is the chart to
really focus on because the PO Haring
period if we just look at this post
Haring period from 2020 starting from
2020 we see reaccumulation here a
breakout from the reaccumulation period
reaccumulation here as well and then a
rally a few weeks of Dipping before
another rally a few weeks of Dipping
before another rally and then we saw
that corrective period take place during
that distribution range but generally
speaking when you focus on this 5day
period of after the
harving pre harving retrace and then
weeks and then weeks of Dipping upside
weeks of Dipping multiple weeks of
upside dipping and that's just how it's
going to be for the remainder of the
post Haring period 500 Days over 500
days so we could see some sort of
reaccumulation in this post hoving
period that could last several weeks
maybe even multiple months and we could
see some sort of sideways action
downside volatility upside volatility
but that would be the last opportunity
before we finally hone in and zoom in
onto the green most parabolic price
action in the post Hing period which
will have a few dips on the way up
but knowing that these are
dips we we'll know that they're dips
because we will only start selling 500
days after the Haring 500 days after the
Haring is typically when we see a bull
market Peak so when we see dips at
around this point for instance then
that's going to be a dip that's a buer
dip opportunity on a retrace if we see a
dip here and a dip here and a dip here
those are going to be opportunities for
reaccumulation before we finally Peak
and the closer we get to the latter
stages of
2025 this is when we should be really
starting to slowly dollar cost average
out of the market taking profit because
that's the post Haring parabolic phase
which also leads us to that final
blowoff top moment and we don't want to
give all our games back to the market
because you can see how quickly those
gains can dissipate quite quickly if we
don't time the market correctly so 500
days after the Hing then we see a
yearlong at least bare Market take place
and it would be a shame to really ride
this parabolic uptrend and not manage to
make the most of that bull Trend and get
caught on this multiple month yearlong
at least bare Market which of course
we've transitioned out of successfully
and now are in the very beginnings of
this new bull market for Bitcoin lots to
look forward to going into the post
harving period we'll have over 500 Days
to enjoy parabolic price action towards
the upside after April
2024 in the meantime however how can we
maximize our opportunity and join the
Train the upside that we're currently
seeing here any pullback during this
preh Haring period is going to be the
very last bargain buying opportunity for
Bitcoin we've only seen very few bargain
buying opportunities for Bitcoin in this
preh harving period reaccumulation
sideways ranges or even entire crashes
we might not get a massive crash like we
did in 2019 maybe we do get some sort of
reaccumulation that highs and a 20%
retrace within that reaccumulation
period could occur any deeper retrace
however during this period is that time
to really make the most of because it's
this deep retrace that's going to be one
of the last moments for
reaccumulation this preh Haring retrace
also one of the last moments for
reaccumulation as well before we really
take off and then that reaccumulation
period straight after the harving those
are the three checkpoints that lie ahead
that we really need to make the most of
and take advantage to properly position
ourselves for that parabolic uptrend
that's probably going to end 500 days
after the harving closer to the end of
2025 mid September to Mid October thank
you so much for watching subscribe to
the channel for more videos like this in
the future like this video If you
enjoyed this video and check out the top
right hand corner video for more I'll
speak to you in the next one